la parole est maintenant à Madame
Natacha Bouchard pour le groupe
UMP
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
aujourd'hui c'est à la fois l'élu de
cette Haute Assemblée
et le maire d'une des communes les plus
pauvres de France qu'elle est qui
s'adresse à vous
vous le savez la politique de la ville
comprend l'ensemble des actions
visant à lutter contre les phénomènes
d'exclusion des populations
urbaines défavorisées la politique de la
ville s'intéresse donc au quartier en
crise
depuis ces prémices dans les années 70
jusqu'aux émeutes urbaines de novembre
2005 la politique de la ville est restée
une politique incertaine quant à l'objet
qu'elle se donne aux perspectives qui
sont les siennes à son statut dans
l'action publique
le rappel de son histoire fait
apparaître une scène et une série
d'oscillations du quartier à
l'agglomération
d'un état animateur
voire autoritaire à l'effacement de
l'État au profit des mers d'une
politique d'exception à une politique
avisée d'abord pédagogique du
développement
autocentré du quartier à sa remise à
hauteur de la norme environnante pour
nous la politique de la ville est
d'abord une politique contractuelle une
politique globale embrassant tous les
aspects de la vie quotidienne et une
politique interministérielle
elle doit avoir pour objectif la prise
en compte des territoires en difficulté
au sein des villes par une politique
publique adaptée
elle repose sur trois principes
fondamentaux
mobilisation de l'ensemble des
compétences et des acteurs à l'oeuvre
sur un territoire
contractualisation entre ces acteurs et
pour l'état des marches
interministérielles
ces principes ont été maintenus lorsque
le périmètre d'action a été étendue du
quartier à la ville pour permettre de
mieux résoudre des dysfonctionnements
structurels par exemple la desserte en
transport des quartiers qui ne peut se
traiter que dans un plan général de
transport
son champ d'application concerne quatre
domaines majeurs la rénovation
urbaine la sécurité et la prévention de
la délinquance le développement social
et culturel des quartiers enfin le
développement de l'emploi et la
revitalisation économique de ces mêmes
quartiers
c'est sous la présidence de Jacques
Chirac en 2003 que la loi d'orientation
et de programmation pour la ville et la
rénovation
urbaine fut votée
elle a affirmé pour la première fois
l'objectif pour la politique de la ville
de réduire des inégalités sociales et
des écarts de développement entre les
territoires
les écarts concernent à la fois la
population et le territoire en tant que
tel
l'urbain en clavement fonction logement
forme humaine forme
urbaine desserte
l'économique emploie qualité de l'offre
commerciale intégration de fonctions
économiques dans le tissu urbain
existant ceux de flux
et le social insertion formation
réussite scolaire
cette loi a eu pour but de réduire les
inégalités sociales et des écarts de
développement entre les territoires dans
les zones urbaines sensibles notamment
avec la création d'un observatoire
national des US
elle a permis la mise en place du
programme national de rénovation
urbaine dit plan Borlo son objectif pour
la période
2004-2008
2000 constructions de logements sociaux
locatif 200
000 réhabilitations et 200 000
démolitions de logements vétustes
à Calais pour le quartier du beau marais
cela a été la construction de 657
logements dont 308 sur le quartier et
349 hors site le dédansifiant
et nous avons également réhabilité 180
logements puis résidentialisé 593 autres
pour un coût total de 143 millions 8
euros dont 7 millions 8 pour le seul
budget de la ville
c'est aussi grâce à cette loi que
l'Agence nationale pour la rénovation
urbaine a pu voir le jour
plus récemment en 2008 nous avons
soutenu le plan banlieue voulu par le
Président de la République Nicolas
Sarkozy intitulé une nouvelle politique
en faveur des banlieues
la précédente majorité avez-vous lu
faire de nos territoires en difficulté
le lieu d'une dynamique collective qui
mobilise l'ensemble des acteurs
impliqués
cela concernait l'état bien sûr avec le
retour du droit commun dans le cadre
d'un programme triennal porté par chacun
des ministères mais également les
collectivités locales dans le cadre d'un
partenariat responsable et ambitieux et
le monde économique parce que
l'émancipation et l'intégration passe
par un emploi et parce que le retour de
la croissance sera aussi porté par les
habitants des quartiers qui regorgent de
talents
cette dynamique rompait donc avec la
logique curative des plans précédents
car nos quartiers ne sont pas malades
de plus elle n'était pas un catalogue de
mesure mais une politique sur mesure qui
répond aux exigences et aux besoins des
habitants des quartiers
enfin cette nouvelle politique de la
ville se fondait sur une démarche
d'évaluation et une culture de résultats
dans ce but l'Observatoire national des
zones urbaines sensibles que nous avions
voulu indépendant produit chaque année
un rapport sur la situation des
quartiers populaires sujets sur lequel
il apporte un éclairage sans concession
pour pouvoir mettre en œuvre
efficacement cette politique de la ville
rénovée nous avons modifié la
gouvernance
à présent celle-ci s'articule au niveau
national autour d'une instance de
consultation le Conseil national des
Villes d'une instance de décision le
Conseil interministériel des villes et
d'une instance de préparation et
d'exécution le secrétariat général du
comité interministériel des villes
cette réforme a permis une meilleure
visibilité et une meilleure efficacité
la politique de la ville agit
aujourd'hui tant sur le développement
urbain grâce à la rénovation
urbaine et au désenclavant que sur
l'humain grâce à l'accompagnement social
de tous les habitants et notamment les
plus modestes
son volet le plus visible reste bien
entendu celui de la rénovation
urbaine le beau et le vert ne sont plus
aujourd'hui l'apanage des quartiers
aisés
l'ensemble du programme de rénovation
urbaine est ainsi saluée par les élus de
tout bord mais aussi et surtout par les
habitants qui retrouvent considération
dignité lors de la transformation de
leur quartier
pour que le volet urbain de la politique
de la ville soit complet il faut
également articuler la rénovation
urbaine avec le désenclavement les zones
urbaines en difficulté sont trop souvent
excentrés
enclavé coupez des bassins de vie et
d'emploi ce qui isole durablement les
habitants des quartiers populaires
la réduction de cette fracture
territoriale conditionne l'efficacité
des autres actions de la politique de la
ville
il s'agit grâce à une meilleure desserte
par des transports en commun de qualité
de permettre aux habitants d'accéder
plus simplement à l'ensemble de la ville
aux emplois aux équipements publics et
privés aux activités mais également au
service
en reliant ces quartiers aux autres
agglomérations le désenclavement
concourt à la lutte contre le chômage
qui doit être au centre de nos
préoccupations
la situation de l'emploi est
particulièrement difficile vous le savez
des écarts énormes existent entre les
istes et le reste du territoire ce taux
de chômage y est deux fois et demi
supérieur il s'établit à 22%, 7 contre
9,4 dans les zones hors US des villes
qui en comprennent une et le taux de
chômage des 15 24 ans atteint
40,4% contre 21,6 orsus l'éducation doit
être au cœur de notre démarche la
promotion de l'égalité dans l'accès aux
filières d'excellence l'aide aux enfants
en difficulté ainsi que le renforcement
de la sécurité dans les écoles des
quartiers populaires
c'est pourquoi à Calais nous avons mis
en place une politique d'éducation par
le sport alliée à la construction
d'équipements spécifiques dédié gymnase
Gauguin Matisse espace Marino ou encore
zapado
celle-ci consiste à attirer les jeunes
en difficulté vers la pratique sportive
vecteur de règles et de valeur
structurantes
c'est encore l'action aussi que l'on
appelle lecture pour tous dont la mise
en place et la réussite furent saluer
récemment par la presse nationale
sous l'impulsion de Nicolas Sarkozy
l'accès aux filières d'excellence s'est
développée pour la première fois les
classes préparatoires aux grandes écoles
accueillent 30% des boursiers
accentuer nos efforts en faveur de la
mixité sociale passe par l'émergence
d'une élite
issue des quartiers populaires
mais l'emploi et l'éducation ne peuvent
être envisagées sans l'ordre public
en effet seul l'ordre républicain peut
permettre l'émancipation sociale et
économique des citoyens
aussi nous devons nous battre jusqu'au
bout pour faire reculer la violence dans
les quartiers
aucune politique ne peut se développer
et être mise en œuvre sereinement dans
un contexte local perturbé
le gouvernement doit donc renforcer son
action d'autant plus que les territoires
de la politique de la ville ont
particulièrement souffert de la crise
leurs habitants ne doivent pas être
laissés sur le bord de la route qui nous
mène à la reprise économique
au-delà des réflexions sur les
dispositifs la politique de la ville a
besoin de réforme structurantes
profondes afin d'accélérer la réduction
des écarts territoriaux et donc des
inégalités sociales
je pense bien entendu à la réforme de la
géographie prioritaire à celle de la
péréquation et à une nouvelle
contractualisation monsieur le ministre
l'expérience nous apprend qu'une
politique trop générale dit du tout et
ne résout rien
en revanche plus on concentre les moyens
sur les territoires en difficulté plus
les politiques sont efficaces
je souhaiterais donc que votre
gouvernement puisse cibler certains
quartiers de façon objective là où les
revenus des habitants sont les plus
faibles où les taux d'emploi sont les
plus bas où la proportion des jeunes est
importante ou la part de logement
sociaux témoigne de l'absence de mixité
sociale
la réforme de la Politique de la Ville
doit permettre de répondre à la
situation de certains quartiers qui
aujourd'hui faute d'être en zone urbaine
sensible ne bénéficie pas de tous les
dispositifs d'accompagnement de l'État
si l'augmentation de la solidarité de
l'État a été d'une grande aide pour
certaines communes en difficulté comme
la mienne elle n'a réglé en quelque
sorte que la partie en amont du problème
des villes pauvres en rapprochant leur
ressources de la ressource moyenne des
communes la réforme n'a pas été
suffisante pour prendre en charge une
part significative des dépenses
exceptionnelles auxquelles ces communes
doivent faire face
dans bien des cas les crédits
spécifiques de la politique de la ville
ont dû également contribuer à la remise
à niveau des situations locales
difficiles avant de financer les besoins
en équipement et services des
populations concernées je vous donnerai
encore quelques exemples quand j'ai
repris Calais après 37 ans d'abandon
j'ai dû investir chaque année environ 2
millions d'euros dans la seule
réhabilitation des écoles un million et
demi en moyenne dans la réhabilitation
des routes et des trottoirs je ne parle
pas de l'éclairage public dont la veste
m'obligerait à dépenser si j'en avais
les moyens 19 millions d'euros juste
pour la remise au norme compte tenu de
l'ampleur de la tâche je fais chaque
année des investissements touche partout
afin de tout remettre au niveau au fur
et à mesure bien entendu je dois
également appliquer on croit mon
programme d'investissement nouveau tout
en faisant face à une dette de 100
millions d'euros c'est pourquoi je suis
particulièrement soulagée quand je
reçois une aide de 8 millions d'euros
pour la déesseu ou encore une aide
supplémentaire pour la ddeu à hauteur
d'un million d'euros qui me donne une
petite bouffée d'oxygène pour mes
finances et mon programme comme dans
bien d'autres domaines ce constat
relatif à l'adéquation des ressources et
des charges laisse à penser que l'on
demande à la politique de la ville de
régler des problèmes de portée générale
avec des moyens inadaptés en effet le
vrai clivage réside d'abord dans la
distorsion entre villerich et ville
pauvre le chemin pour réduire les
inégalités territoriales et sociales est
encore long
et le courage politique ne suffira pas
monsieur le ministre cet ensemble
au-delà de nos clivages politiques que
nous y parviendrons et sur ce chemin je
me porte volontaire pour participer avec
mes autres collègues qui sont intervenus
ce jour pour d'autres réunions de
travail en commun il en va de la
cohésion républicaine qui fait le socle
de notre démocratie je vous remercie